alô
boa noite a todos
bom eu vou começar a falar um pouquinho
sobre essa notícia que eu me deparei há
mais ou menos um mês
achei muito interessante porque ela
começa com o seguinte título o conceito
de sucesso mudou
ninguém avisou a gente e 72 por cento
dos jovens eles acreditam em uma nova
definição para o sucesso linkedin fez
uma pesquisa com aproximar
aproximadamente quatro mil jovens
esses jovens entendem agora que o
sucesso está relacionado a palavra
felicidade
eu parei pra pensar quando o sucesso não
ter ligado à felicidade
mas o que mais me eu mais me intrigou
foi lendo um pouco mais essa matéria
falando assim e 60% dos jovens de até 21
anos acreditam já ter sucesso
eu não sei vocês mas a minha geração eu
tenho 29 anos ea gente sempre perseguiu
sucesso a gente assistia aqueles
desenhos do audi onde o tio patinhas
nadava no meio do das moedas mansões
enfim é desde criança eu fui acostumado
que sucesso era exatamente o ganho
financeiro ou exatamente esse é sucesso
profissional e foi aí que comecei a
perceber que o sucesso estava mudando
quando os jovens de até 21 anos já vem
com o pop de sucesso
eu vou começar contando um pouco da
minha história para vocês para vocês
entenderem porque eu percebo tanto essa
palavra sucesso
esse sou eu em 2014 eu tinha de 23 para
24 anos mais ou menos estava muito feliz
nessa foto que tinha acabado de que tal
meu carro todo mundo sabe não só os
jovens que boleto é um grande pesadelo
na nossa vida né nos últimos três anos
eu estava trabalhando numa das maiores
empresas do mercado financeiro
nesses três anos eu tinha eu tinha
passado por três promoções consecutivas
eu era um dos mais na verdade mais jovem
da minha equipe então tinha de fato
conseguir um certo destaque profissional
dentro desse destaque o tinha
conquistado algumas passagens
internacionais como por exemplo tinha
ido pra buenos aires também tinha ido
pra cancun desculpa foto horrível mas
enfim de fato com 23 e com 24 anos eu
tinha alcançado que todo jovem
acreditava e era sucesso na sua carreira
foi então que não tinha
meu chefe me chamou e é pra conversar
com ele sair daqui sorocaba lá pra
campinas quando entrei na sala dele ele
fechou a porta ele falou luís
você é um dos jovens mais promissores
que eu conheço e talvez oferecer pra
você a maior oportunidade profissional
da sua vida
eu vou tirar férias neste mês e eu quero
que você cuide aqui da nossa filial você
vai cuidar do pintado estado do interior
do estado de são paulo inteiro de oito
filiais fazer a gestão é de uma equipe
de aproximadamente 20 pessoas e se você
conseguir um bom resultado
você provavelmente vai ficar na sucessão
da gerência regional e você
provavelmente vai ser o jovem mais jovem
que conquistou esse cargo até hoje
eu acho que nesse momento eu entendi um
pouco do gosto do que é sucesso
ela entende um pouco que de fato faz a
gente sentir que a gente vive é o ser
reconhecido e aí eu falei chefe eu
agradeço muito essa oportunidade você de
fato e mostra a liderança eu adoro o que
eu faço eu amo a equipe o trabalho de
fato eu sou feliz aqui hoje
só que eu acredito que isso não está em
causa o meu propósito eu acredito que de
fato o que eu faço hoje não é o que eu
quero fazer o resto da vida e isso me
faz feliz
então provavelmente daqui um mês vou
pedir demissão você vai fazer o quê da
sua vida para eu abrir uma fábrica de
sabonetes ensinar às pessoas e às
mulheres a gerar renda eu acredito que
assim eu posso ser melhor para o mundo
e aí ele me olhou mais ou menos com uma
cara assim entendeu muito bem o que
estava acontecendo e não só ele mas
diversas outras pessoas começaram a
perguntar luiz que está acontecendo com
você você está deixando o emprego
extremamente estável uma grande
oportunidade de negócios para abrir é
uma fábrica de sabonetes enfim você de
fato entrar num em algo totalmente
arriscado e foi aí que eu comecei a
parar para pensar que foi nesse momento
que eu deixei de ser o homem e todo
mundo queria que eu fosse para assumir o
protagonismo da minha vida e se a pessoa
que realmente eu queria ser o mundo de
fato abrir empresa de sabonete ela deu
certo por um tempo mas claro que não foi
isso que eu queria na minha vida
serviu para aprender de fato como era
ser um empreendedor como era abrir uma
empresa e também serviu para alguns
micos na minha vida mas o que me serviu
para aprender que muito mais vezes do
que é sucesso na sua vida
você tem que descobrir o que não é
sucesso pra você às vezes a gente está
muito acomodado nosso espaço achando que
aquilo de melhor que a gente pode ter na
nossa vida a gente acha que é onde a
gente está hoje o que de melhor a gente
pode conquistar a gente não olha para o
lado a gente sair da nossa zona de
conforto acreditando que a gente pode
conquistar algo de melhor começando do
zero
bom foi aí que eu comecei a me perguntar
o que de fato é sucesso na nossa vida e
é dizer essa palavra pra gente e se de
fato sucesso tá ligado à ganho
financeiro será que de fato felicidade e
sucesso e ganhar dinheiro eles estão
intrinsecamente relacionados e comecei a
perceber que a gente aprendeu na escola
um tal de mazo da pirâmide de maslow ele
começa falando o seguinte você começa
nas suas necessidades fisiológicas
depois você vai pra sua necessidade de
segurança necessidades sociais você
alcança ao time depois você pensa na
auto realização e aí eu achei que mais
eu estava me enganando porque andei a
pirâmide inteira e quando cheguei lá na
ponta eu tive que de extreme minha
pirâmide construir uma nova e eu comecei
a perceber que não é isso que traz
sucesso pra gente que talvez as nossas
necessidades estão começando a mudar um
pouco né
talvez até pirâmide de maslow precisa de
um pouco de revisão aqui né e aí eu
comecei a entender e e procurará onde
algumas teorias que faz de fato
quisessem sentido para a gente entender
o que é sucesso na nossa vida e aí eu me
deparei com uma pesquisa muito
interessante de richard ele é o paradoxo
de einstein onde ele pesquisou mais de
60 países
ele começou a a entender se os ganhos do
pib per capita ou seja os ganhos
financeiros das pessoas elas estão
intrinsecamente ligados ao sucesso ea
felicidade
bom o que ele chegou à conclusão que ok
de fato quando você passa às suas
necessidades fisiológicas o ganho
financeiro está assim atrelado à sucesso
ea felicidade mas existe um determinado
momento e é você ganha dinheiro mas
aquele sucesso aquela felicidade ela não
acompanha a sua carreira a sua vida e
mais acho que o dado mais importante
dessa pesquisa foi e países com maior
nível de desigualdade
a sensação de sucesso dentro deles é
menor
não importa se você está dentro de um
país se você é o mais rico mais pobre
mas países mais desiguais que não
conseguem distribuir a riqueza eles têm
as pessoas dentro dela com menos
sensação de sucesso
foi aí que comecei a entender o sucesso
não sou eu
o sucesso não é você sucesso somos nós
sucesso é como nós participamos da
sociedade como nós nos entregamos para o
mundo e como o mundo se entrega pra
gente
entendendo um pouco mais agora que o
sucesso não é só eu não é só você somos
nós eu comecei a pensar tá certo mas
quando que se a gente começa a pensar na
nossa vida em sucesso e felicidade
e aí eu me encontrei com uma pergunta
que talvez a pergunta que foi a pergunta
mais feita pra mim e pra vocês na sua
infância que é
o que você quer ser quando crescer eu
acho que todos vocês passaram por essa
pergunta e quando eu me encontrei com
isso quando eu quando era criança de 7 a
10 anos
enquanto meus amigos queriam ser jogador
de futebol ou atores
eu queria ser presidente da república
não porque era o poder máximo ou porque
eu ia ter o maior escalam mas acreditava
que o presidente da república ele
conseguirá atingir o maior nível de
transformação social ele conseguiu de
fato impactar a vida das pessoas
é por isso que eu queria ser presidente
da república e eu comecei a perguntar o
que eu perdi no meio desse caminho
quando eu era criança eu deixei de
querer transformar a vida das pessoas e
transformar a sociedade e eu só agora e
eu comecei a perceber que dentro da
nossa vida a gente desiste da gente
mesmo só uma informação muito
interessante para a gente chegar nessa
constatação é que a gente vai chegar
agora no começo do ano e no final o
começo do ano provavelmente vocês vão
fazer algumas promessas na vida de vocês
né esse ano vou começar emagrecendo ou
eu vou começar é trocando de emprego só
que provavelmente 79% das pessoas que
estão aqui no primeiro mês já vão
desistir dos seus sonhos ou das suas
conquistas
se a gente desiste de coisas que a gente
quer no começo do ano no primeiro mês
imagina da sua vida imagina quanta coisa
você deixou para trás o que você fazia
parte da sua essência que você não se
conecta mais com isso
dentro disso né depois que eu comecei a
entender um pouco mais sobre
autoconhecimento sucesso é onde eu ia
chegar e trabalhar em diversas
organizações sociais
comecei a trabalhar o empreendedorismo
trabalha em uma organização social que
fazem incubadora de empresas
enfim conheci muita gente boa e uma
dessas pessoas foi sequer chamado mateus
tumulto que chamou muita atenção porque
esse jovem estudou em escola pública
aprendendo sozinho o prefeito nas
maiores universidades dos estados unidos
eu tive o prazer de conviver com ele eu
perguntei mateus
de fato você fez para conseguir tamanho
sucesso ele falou não sei eu só fui
atrás do que eu queria
conversando um pouco com ele eu percebi
nesse exato ponto e para que ele pudesse
ser aceito nas cinco maiores
universidades
ele teve 2000 desistências ou seja
ele e sucesso em 5 ele fracassou mais de
duas mil vezes e aí pensando um pouco na
minha história e pensando um pouco na
história do mateus eu cheguei à seguinte
conclusão e fracasso
bem antes do sucesso e quando as pessoas
aqui estão dispostas a fracassar
quantos de vocês de fato quando
fracassam pensam eu vou fazer de novo e
vou fazer de novo e eu vou fazer de novo
eu acho que é esse momento que a gente
tem que parar para pensar e falar
será que eu dou uma nova oportunidade os
meus sonhos será que de fato é nesse
momento que eu desisto
eu paro de pensar em mim ou eu vou em
frente
uma outra coisa que eu perguntei pro
mateus foi matheus legal você já fez e
mate já fez harvard e agora o sucesso
pra você e falando isso parece que o
game over na minha vida
já fiz tudo mas foi aí que eu percebi
quando você conquista ou quando você vai
conquistar alguma coisa você tem que
começar a se perguntar qual é o meu
valor no mundo
o valor financeiro é qual é o valor que
você entrega para o mundo né
e mais do que o valor que você tem
como eu uso esse valor para transformar
o mundo isso ficou martelando na minha
cabeça eu comecei a pensar e eu quero
fazer é transformar o mundo o potencial
eo valor que eu tenho
e aí eu percebi que eu quero transformar
o mundo através de boas políticas
públicas e de educação para jovens e eu
comecei a buscar o meu sucesso
e foi a partir de então eu comecei a
entender isso e eu consegui hoje seu
assessor na câmara federal legislativa e
também eu tenho um projeto com mateus
onde a gente já impactou mais de mil
jovens diretamente comentou elias
e isso foi muito legal porque eu tive a
oportunidade de viajar o brasil inteiro
e conversar com diversos jovens enfim eu
tive de fato o impacto social na vida
desses mais de mil jovens e isso não é
pra eles é por mim é o meu sucesso
e aí dentro dessas melhorias que a gente
faz desses bate papos para jovem eu
comecei a perceber
uma coisa muito interessante nessa
seguinte pergunta bom tá batendo um papo
e aproximadamente 20 jovens eu fiz essa
pergunta qual é o lugar mais rico da
terra quando jovens falou é dubai tem
petróleo em riqueza enfim o outro falou
a escola é a escola tem é cheia de
conhecimento é cheia de oportunidades e
um amigo meu falou william
assim luís eu acredito no lugar mais
rico da terra
o cemitério cemitério vai ser um lugar
mais rico da terra evoluísse imagina só
quantos médicos que não se tomaram estão
ali os professores que não não
lecionarão que estão ali dentro
quantos sonhos que morreram junto com as
pessoas que estão ali ali onde os sonhos
morreram
onde a gente não realizou aquilo que a
gente queria
e aí eu percebi que a gente não morre
quando a gente desiste
então se você desistiu de algum sonho
que você tinha e eu acho que é mais
interessante do que a gente tentar
formular alguma coisa é uma cartilha do
que é sucesso na nossa vida eu acho que
o sucesso não tem descrição sucesso é
uma coisa que cada um tem o seu
consentimento e cada um tem o seu
entendimento de sucesso
o que eu mais acredito é não importa na
verdade quantas vezes você respondeu que
é sucesso para você mas de fato é
quantas vezes você se perguntar ao longo
da sua carreira ou da sua vida o que
você tem cnpc é isso muito obrigado